in this video I want to tackle some
inequalities that involve multiplying
and dividing by positive and negative
numbers and you'll see that's a little
bit more tricky than just the adding and
subtracting numbers that we saw in the
last video and I also want to introduce
you to some other types of notations for
describing the solution set of an
inequality so let's do a couple of
examples so let's say I had negative 0.5
is X is less than or equal to seven
point five now if this was an equality
your natural impulse to say hey let's
divide both sides by the coefficient on
the x-term
and that is a completely legitimate
thing to do divide both sides by
negative 0.5 the important thing you
need to realize though when you do it
with an inequality is that when you
multiply or divide both sides of the
equation by a negative number you swap
the inequality you swap the inequality
think of it this way I'll do a simple
example here if I were to tell you that
one is less than two I think you would
agree with that one is definitely less
than two now what happens if I multiply
both sides of this by negative one
negative one versus negative two well
all of a sudden negative two is more
negative than negative one so here
negative two is actually less than
negative one now this isn't the proof
but I think it'll give you comfort on
why you're swapping the sign if
something is larger when you take the
negative of both of it it'll be more
negative or vice versa so that's why if
we're going to multiply both sides of
this equation or divide both sides of
the equation by a negative number we
need to swap the sign so let's multiply
both sides of this equation dividing by
dividing by 0.5 is the same thing as
multiplying by two our whole goal here
is to have a 1 coefficient there so
let's multiply both sides of this
equation by negative 2 so we have
negative 2 times negative 0.5 you might
say hey how'd it sound get this to here
my hope my brain is just thinking what
can I multiply negative 0.5
by to get one and negative 0.5 is the
same thing as negative 1/2 the inverse
of that is negative 2 so I'm multiplying
negative 2 times both sides of this
equation and I have the 7.5 on the other
side I'm going to multiply that by
negative 2 as well and remember when you
multiply or divide both sides of an
inequality by a negative you swap the
inequality you had less than or equal
now it will be greater than or equal so
the left-hand side negative 2 times
negative 0.5 is just 1 you get X is
greater than or equal to 7 point 5 times
negative 2 that's negative 15 which is
our solution set all X is larger than
negative 15 will satisfy this equation I
challenge you to try it for example 0
will work 0 is greater than negative 15
but try something like try negative 16
negative 16 will not work negative 16
times 0.5 but times negative 0.5 is 8
which is not less than 7.5 so the
solution set is all of the X's let me
draw a number line here greater than
negative 15 so that is negative 15 there
maybe that's negative 16 that's negative
14 greater than or equal to greater than
or equal to negative 15 is the solution
now you might also see solution sets to
inequalities written in interval
notation an interval notation you just
takes a little getting used to we want
to include negative 15 so our lower
bound to our interval is negative 15 and
putting in this bracket here means that
we're going to include negative 15 the
set includes the bottom boundary it
includes negative 15 and we're going to
go all the way to infinity we're going
to go all the way to infinity and we put
a curly a parenthesis here parentheses
normally means that you're not including
the upper bound you also do it for
infinity because infinity really isn't a
normal number so to speak you can't just
say oh I'm at infinity you're never at
infinity so that's why you put that
parenthesis but the parentheses tends to
mean that you don't
include that boundary but you also use
it with infinity so these this and this
are the exact same thing sometimes you
might also see set notations where the
solution of that they might say X is a
real number real number such that that
little line that vertical line thing
just means such that X is greater than
or equal to negative 15 so this is the
set these curly brackets mean the set of
all real numbers or the set of all
numbers where X is a real number such
that X is greater than or equal to
negative 15 all of this this and this
are all equivalent let's keep that in
mind and do a couple of more examples so
let's say we had 75 X is greater than or
equal to 125 so here we can just divide
both sides by 75 divided both sides by
75 and since 75 is a positive number you
don't have to change the inequality so
you get X is greater than or equal to
125 over 75 and if you divide the
numerator and denominator by 25 this is
5 over 3 so X is greater than or equal
to 5/3 or we can write the solution set
being from including 5/3 to infinity and
once again if you were to graph it on a
number line let's graph it on the number
line 5/3 is what that's 1 and 2/3 so you
have 0 1 2 & 1 and 2/3 will be right
around there we're going to include it
that right there is 5/3 and everything
greater than or equal to that will be
included in our solution set let's do
another one let's let's say we have x
over negative 3 is greater than negative
10 over 9 so we want to just isolate the
X on the left hand side so let's
multiply both sides by
i upon you can imagine is one over
negative one over three so we want to
multiply by the inverse which would be
negative three so if you multiply both
sides by negative three you get negative
three times this is you could rewrite it
as negative one-third X and on this side
you have negative ten over nine times
negative three and the inequality will
switch because we are multiplying or
dividing by a negative number so the
inequality will switch it'll go from
greater than to less than so the
left-hand side of the equation just
becomes an X that was the whole point
that cancels out with that the negatives
cancel out X is less than and then you
have a negative times a negative that
will make it a positive then you if you
divide the numerator in the denominator
by three you get a 1 and a 3 so X is
less than 10 over 3 so if we were to
write this in interval notation the the
solution set will the upper bound will
be 10 over 3 and it won't include 10
over 3 this isn't less than or equal to
so we're going to put up for rent the
C's here notice here it included 5/3 we
put a bracket here we're not including
10 thirds we put a parenthesis and we'll
go from 10 over 3 all the way down to
negative infinity and negative
everything less than 10 over 3 is in our
solution set let's draw that let's draw
the solution set so 10 over 3 so we
might have 0 1 2 3 4 10 over 3 is 3 & 1
thirds so it might sit we do it in a
different color it might be over here
we're not going to include that it's
less than 10 over 3 10 over 3 is not in
the solution set that is 10 over 3 right
there and everything less than that but
not including 10 over 3 is in our
solution set let's do let's do one more
let's do one more say we have x over
negative 15 is less than 8 less than 8
so once again let's well
by both sides of this equation by
negative 15 so negative 15 times x over
negative 15 and then you have it 8 times
a negative 15 and when you multiply both
sides of an inequality by a negative
number or divide both sides by a
negative number you swap the inequality
it's less than you change it to greater
then and now this the left-hand side
just becomes an X because these guys
cancel out X is greater than 8 times 15
is 80 plus 40 is 120 so negative 120 is
that right 80 plus 40 you have negative
120 or we could write the solution set
as starting at negative 120 we're not
including negative 120 we don't have an
equal sign here going all the way up to
infinity and if we either were to graph
it we draw the number line here I'll do
a real quick one let's say that that is
negative 120 maybe 0 sitting up here
this would be negative 121 this would be
negative 119 we are not going to include
negative 120 because we don't have an
equal sign there it's going to be
everything greater than negative 120 all
of these things that I'm shading in
green would satisfy the inequality and
you can even try it out does zero work
zero over 15 yea that's 0 that's
definitely less than 8 I mean that
doesn't prove it to you but you could
try any of these numbers and they should
work anyway hopefully you found that
helpful I'll see you in the next video